hello and welcome back to the shiki-san
show so in this video I thought I'd do
something a bit different and discuss a
recent book that I read and say this
book is a deep medicine written by Eric
Topol and it's about how artificial
intelligence can make health care human
again so I'm gonna tell you about about
this book why I liked it and hopefully
do all of this so that were real and too
many secrets but to give a general
overview about what's discussed in the
book
so bottom line I really really did enjoy
reading this book and I do recommend it
to anyone scientist or non-scientists
because it has many important messages
that you know have curse I mean that's
gonna mean to affect all of us and it's
you know interesting to have his
perspective over where he sees medicine
going in the upcoming years which is
interesting slightly scary at times but
something that we should all be aware of
and so this isn't the first book written
by table but it's the first book of his
that I've read all the way Fred's other
authors were a few articles before and
so I really like the subtitle to his
book about the idea of making health
care human again the fact that we've
kind of lost this doctor-patient
relationship over time and the
juxtaposition of that human contact with
artificial intelligence and so this
famous obviously carried out throughout
the entirety of the book so this
absolutely new prereqs equipped to
reading this book to begin with the book
starts looking at where artificial
intelligence is already at and so
discusses examples where AI ice has been
used to match the top chess players in
the world which are pretty cool and
before it goes into where AI is being
used in healthcare and I suppose one of
the biggest fears with artificial
intelligence is that AI can be used to
take haver jobs and what are people
going to be doing you know in 25 years
time when AI can do your job better than
you can
well some of the healthcare professions
discussed in this book includes surgeons
where is currently predicted it'd be
about 30 years before AI could do a
better job but for AI researchers this
could take up to 85 years but it's not
all doom and gloom because artificial
intelligence could open up different
jobs that current really we can't even
imagine being jobs and also exciting
because the idea of using AI is not to
competes but to combine with our current
workforce and to help make things more
efficient and effective for example they
could be used to help produce the error
rates look engineer we all make mistakes
right and a great example used in the
book is of a test whereby they
deliberately put in a gorilla in two
different scans and got radiologists to
examine them and um you know a
significant amount of them failed to
notice there was actually a gorilla in
the scan it's quite funny but alongside
the concerns the use of AI the other
concerns that are kind of emphasized
throughout the book is why are we doing
this who benefits from this use of
artificial intelligence and so topal
references from the book home ideas and
the kind of interesting quotes that 20th
century medicine was to heal the sick
whilst the 21st century is aiming to
upgrade the healthy and is the kind of
fear that is only the rich going to
benefits from misuse of artificial
intelligence and the kind of ethical and
social concerns that needs to be
considered alongside with this advances
in AI in medical research and healthcare
but what I like most about this book was
the idea that we kind of need to reframe
the the methods use the medicine to see
13a the modern world and to regain this
human patient doctor-patient
relationship and there's created by
Hippocrates it is more important to know
what sort of person has a
than today what sort of disease a person
has but to be able to use as a preach
you need to have individual patient data
and this is where artificial
intelligence could really advance and
achieve this because especially with
smartphones and the easiness now of
getting genetic information this could
definitely be a way of getting a wealth
of information about different patients
and that information is unique to that
patient and can enable informative
decisions to be made so one thing that
kind of amazed me from reading the book
was just the amount of information that
can be accessed from your smartphone say
not only the usage of what different
apps are using it also includes like the
speech when you have a phone
conversation photos keyboard usage so
how fast you're typing and the quality
or the Tyrian of the voice could
potentially be used as well as like face
sensors I mean a name is means now you
have the fingerprint sensors to sign in
but the facial recognition could also be
something that you know it could go
somewhere as well as other senses or
like heart rates which could be really
useful for pre-emptive heart diseases um
and so whilst is great yeah it's all the
information which could be really useful
for being like oh you might get this
disease it's kind of scary because you
know he really owns this information and
how much you know what about privacy you
know this isn't though you know raises
really interesting points throughout the
book about the great aspects also the
hazards and warnings associated with AI
in health care but by combining all this
data with your age gender weight
genetics proteomics and your guts
microbiome if you get to the point where
we have these so-called virtual medical
assistants on our phone devices whereby
you know I could wake up one morning and
be informed of what I should be eating
that day or how much sleep I should be
getting so one initial problem is
that this kind of all depends on human
behavior if Massa got abs upon what I'm
being told but the second question is
well where's the states are coming from
so as I've already mentioned this
depends on the information that can be
gathered from your phone and brief from
like some experimentation I'm that's but
in terms of getting the outputs this can
sometimes depends on information already
gained from other individuals and so one
thing that could be used in the future
is the idea of having a digital playing
multiple with digital twins and
effectively that individuals who may to
assemble all the demographic biologic
physiologic and anatomic criteria of the
person or the patient's we're talking
about
and by updating this information
multiple times based some results from
other people it can enable more precise
or accurate diagnostics and
recommendations for the latest patients
and so as I mentioned earlier one of the
themes of the book is about bringing
back the human aspect to health care
again and so in one of the last chapters
it really emphasizes the points and
tries to address the question of by the
robots could eventually replace or
reproduce human doctors so besides
empathy there's a whole range of you
know human characteristics that they
really do define us and make us human so
this non exhaustive list includes
features such as being able to love
laugh cry dream be afraid grieve joy
trust in care for sufferer explore tell
stories and jokes inspired by curious
creative be grateful or not miss the
kind generous intuitive and innovative
and this human human connection is kind
of needed for a patient thoughts
relationship since it provides these
elements of trust and also comfort in
times of distress and so one of the
final thoughts from the book is is it
that these features of what we should be
looking for in selection of future
doctors and how can people be trained to
really reinforce these human features so
I can only really say thank you to Eric
for such an insightful book which I
really do recommend that you read and I
hope that this videos
provided a somewhat brief but good
enough overview to make you want to read
the book in much more detail so thanks
for listening